welcome to the presentation on exponents
so first of all let's let's just figure
out what an exponent is
so if i write
2
to the third power
what i'm actually saying is that i'm
going to multiply two times itself three
times
so it's two
times two
times two and we know two times two is
four and four times two is equal to
eight
when you first are doing exponents
you're tempted to think that two to the
third is equal to two times three
but the difference is two times three
actually means two plus
two
plus two
which equals six
so a way you could view it is exponents
are to multiplication just as
multiplication is to addition i hope i'm
not confusing you let's do a bunch of
more problems and hopefully it'll become
self-explanatory
so 4 squared well that just equals
4 times 4
which is equal to 16.
5
to the third power well that would just
be five
times five
times five
which equals well five times five is 25
times five that equals 125.
i think you're getting the the picture
now and and the every time you you'll
you'll do it you'll you'll be able to
figure it out and then when you come
back a week later you might forget
you'll say two to the third oh that's
six because your brain will say two
times three but you just have to
remember no that's two
times itself three times so it's two
times two times two
let's do some more
so what happens if i have
negative three
to the second power
well let's just think it through that
equals negative 3
times
negative 3.
and what's a negative times a negative
right it's a positive
so that equals positive
9.
let's figure out what negative 3
to the third power is
well once again we could just write it
out it's negative 3
times negative 3
times
negative three
well negative three times negative three
we already figured out that's nine and
we have to multiply that times negative
three
and now we have
nine times negative three they're
opposite signs so we get negative
27. so it's interesting when you have a
negative number to the second power you
get a positive number you got in this
case negative 3 squared equal 9. when
you had a negative number to a
to the third power we got another a
negative number so if you think about it
whenever you have a negative number to
an even power it becomes a positive
number and whenever you have a negative
number to an odd power it becomes a
negative number i hope i didn't confuse
you maybe this this will hit the point
home
so negative one
to the first power well that just equals
negative one
negative one to the second power
would equal
negative one times negative one and we
know that that just equals one
negative one
to the third power
well that's negative one times negative
one
times negative one
negative one times negative one is one
times negative one well that's negative
one again negative 1 to the fourth power
is negative 1 times negative 1 times
negative 1 times negative 1.
and all the negatives end up canceling
out and you get a 1.
so you see that when we get to the first
power we got a negative one we did the
second power we got a positive one we
get to the third power we got a negative
one again we to the fourth power it
became positive again i hope i'm not
confusing you
let's do some more problems
if i were to say
5
to the 4th power
let's say negative 5 to the 4th power
well that's negative 5
times negative 5
times negative 5 times negative 5.
negative 5 times negative 5 is positive
25
and we can just do it this way we could
say well negative 5 times negative 5
that's positive 25 as well and 25 times
25 is equal to 625.
so there's really nothing we're learning
new here it's just multiplication when
we say negative 5 to the fifth fourth
negative 5 to the fourth power we're
just multiplying negative five by itself
four times
now let me show you a um
i'll maybe do another module on
explaining this uh in terms of why this
works out intuitively but one thing to
remember is anything to the zeroth power
equals one
so one to the zero power
equals one
two to the zero zero power equals one
you know one thousand
to the zero
zero that's the zero power equals one
and anything to the first power just
equals a number so 15
to the first power that equals 15
negative three fifths
to the first power well that equals
negative three-fifths
and now just to hopefully fully confuse
you i'm gonna
add one more element here i'll do a
fraction so if i said negative 3 over 4
to the second power
i think you might be able to work this
one out you might want to pause it and
try it yourself
well that just equals negative
three-fourths
times
negative three-fourths
so you multiply the numerators and the
negatives negative times a negative is a
positive so it becomes nine
over sixteen
and you might notice that 9 over 16 is
the same thing as if we had negative 3
squared
over 4 squared
i don't want to confuse you too much but
later on we'll see this is actually one
of the properties of exponents if you
raise a whole fraction to an exponent
it's the same as raising the numerator
of the exponent divided by the
denominator of that exponent
let's do a couple more
so if i said
5
5 over 12
squared well that equals 25 over 144
5 times 5 is 25 12 times 12 is 144.
if i said
say two thirds
to the third power well that's
two-thirds
times the dot is just another way to
write times two-thirds times two-thirds
and that equals two times two times two
over three
times three times three
this numerator two times two times two
well that just equals eight
the denominator three times three times
three well that just equals twenty seven
so we have two thirds to the third power
equals eight over twenty-seven i think
you might have gotten the picture by now
pretty much if you have
any number let's just say you had the
number a i hope it will confuse using
these variables to let's say